[Music]
[Music]
Douglas we're gonna be talking about
your column this week
um but that kind of It kind of follows
on from your column last week so can you
tell us a bit about that for anyone who
dared to missed it of course if anyone
missed it um I wrote last week about the
events that have been going on in
Leicester uh in recent weeks really
since the end of last month when there's
been Community tensions between the
Hindu community and the Muslim Community
as a result really was started it seems
because of a cricket match at the end of
August
um and things got really nasty there and
I talked among other things about the
fact that here were two groups of you
know young men a lot of them seem to be
or at least some of them seem to be
carrying some form of arms and uh things
are getting very ropey and the local
police were there as a thin yellow line
I mentioned in passing that um there
were several women there with sticks and
it didn't seem to be entirely adequate
necessarily for two very very you know
gung-ho groups of young men and I
mentioned in passing that of course I
don't know if there was a much trans
representation or indeed were there any
gays at the event because they weren't
whether or not and whether or not they
were dancing the Macarena which is what
we now expect of course of lgbtqi plus
offices as we know so I mentioned that
in passing as a real dig just at the
fact that for years the British police
have put diversity they advertise
diversity as the main thing they don't
really bother if you get your bike
stolen they don't really bother if you
get your house robbed they don't even
look of CCTV but they love to paint
their cars rainbow they love to have
photograph high heels and much more and
so I think that uh you know one of my
basic rules is that if you make yourself
ridiculous you should expect to be
ridiculed you shouldn't make yourself
ridiculous and then when somebody
ridicules you say how dare you what
would make you do that so you're writing
about a serious issue yeah sectarian
violence breaking out in the streets of
Midlands people getting hurt might
spread violence you get a response to
your erps from the police what does that
say yeah and that's what you're writing
about this week and literally what the
comment I just made was that there was a
throwaway comment
humorous if I may say so myself
and the police turned out to be enraged
by it uh the um I I read actually since
I got in front of me uh what the chief
Constable of West Midlands police wrote
he he wrote a letter to our editor
my boss he dobbed me in and he said
among other things he said if Mr Murray
were to rise from his comfortable chair
and toddle up to the West Midlands he
would find plenty of women and LGBT
officers more than capable of putting
him on his backside if he came at them
waving his sharp fountain pen now that's
the David Thompson who's the chief
Constable of West Midlands police uh he
he went on to say that that his his men
and men women and these I assume know
very well how to deal with the thugs
they confront keeping the king's piece
so it's interesting he called the Muslim
gangs thugs
um but anyway and then then others
joined in Louisa Rolfe and assistant
commissioner of the Metropolitan Police
here in London added that she said to me
we have room in a carrier for you so so
a chief Constable promised that he could
his officers could throw could put me
onto my backside I.E beat me up and then
his colleague at uh the Metropolitan
Police promised they've got a police van
for me this is this is for making a dig
at the stupidity of the British police's
behavior in recent years on these issues
and I think it is so telling for a
number of reasons one is it's a great
reminder of the fact that the that the
British police have gone mad and this is
12 years into a conservative government
and there's no excuse for it people at
the top of the police like the chief
Council of West Britain's police sir
David Thompson not only to get knighted
but they get they get they get wafted
all the way up by doing this sort of
thing they're all political actors of
these they're not really interested in
policing they're interested in saying
the right things to get themselves
advanced in the police force so that
that's the first thing the second thing
is West Midlands police has a shocking
reputation as its own it's well known a
problem police force and I'm glad to
David Thompson has reminded us all of
that about about uh 12 years ago uh when
Channel 4 revealed that there were there
were uh preachers in in the West
Midlands area preaching Jihad and they
did this they put Channel 4 showed us in
a documentary who did the West Midlands
police and Sir David Thompson's
colleagues go for they didn't go for the
preacher they didn't go for the jihadis
they didn't go for the people who were
threatening the lives of other British
citizens no they decided to go for
channel four so so this is this is
actually just another example of the
fact that British police is in deep
disarray I think I think people like sir
David Thompson and Louisa Rolfe should
be absolutely ashamed of themselves I
don't consider this a threat I'm a big
enough boy to be able to take it but I
don't really expect Chief constables and
assistant Commissioners and Metropolitan
Police to be threatening journalists I
mean you mentioned your piece
um about the fact you know the police
have been doing the Macarena the biggest
Pride festivals they seem to be they've
taken the knee in London yeah there
seems to be sort of a clear political
agenda of the police do you think it's
kind of linked on us it's almost about
being seen as righteous online and
that's why they're sort of coming for
you well of course I mean it was it's
been like this ever since the MacPherson
report they've just overcompensated on
everything
um and and you know we see this on a
daily basis I mean the the the the way
they behave about Pride now is
absolutely sickling but as I say in the
piece it makes me start to feel really
quite homophobic I have to say I mean I
mean seriously getting your offices mail
offices to wear high heels and go sort
of ooh as if as a woman I'm a woman
maybe I'm a they maybe I'm a non-binary
it's like no stop people's houses
getting burgled like lock up rapists and
murderers and they've got really
terrible racist if you look at some of
these police forces like the West
Midlands please if you look at actual
rates of catching people for what they
regard as minor crimes it's absolutely
appalling they don't bother chasing up
this stuff oh oh but they love doing the
Macarena Manchester Pride to show how on
board with the gays they are I don't
give a damn about that stuff I'd be very
surprised if most British citizens give
a damn about that stuff what we do give
a damn about is our police officers
becoming political and political and
Incredibly ugly left-wing agenda
Direction and I said we mentioned as
well there's been another incident with
the police this week where Sussex police
uh they'd well pedophile had been
convicted essentially for abusing a
large number of people they now identify
as a woman and he identifies as a woman
he evangelizes a woman quite
um and he raped the kids when he was a
man when he was a man and throughout the
court case he's referred to as a man
actually because that's when his actions
took place like that and someone had the
temerity to sort of describe this person
as as a man and they were ticked off
online by Sussex police I mean what do
you make is coming from it's another
it's an even more obscene example of
what I just described where you know you
do the Macarena but you don't bother
with burglaries to to police pronouns
and and put the priority of a sex
offender pedophile rapists pronoun
preferences over an accurate description
of the crime and for the police to think
that's their role it's so sickening like
what does it matter whether you
misgender the person it you're not
misgendering anyway all that's happened
on this occasion is a male pedophile
rapist has been convicted and has since
tried to dress up and approximate the
look of a woman that's it West Midlands
police or any other police force Sussex
police they can have all sorts of views
about what pronouns doesn't matter a
damn the only thing that matters is that
that man is convicted if he's guilty and
he's sentenced to prison and he spends
the rest of his life in prison that
would be a good outcome why are Sussex
police policing
um pronouns for the same reason that the
police in this this country that still
tries to be serious on occasion that
this this formerly serious country has
police officers turning up at people's
doors telling the them that their
thoughts are wrong or that they're that
they've tweeted something online that
could cause somebody else distress we've
got a new Home Secretary Sarah bravaman
she thank goodness responded actually
very swiftly to the latest stupidity
from Sussex police
here's a challenge to swella Bravo if
she's watching you may well be the last
conservative Home Secretary for some
decades at the at the rate at which the
conservatives have been failing over the
last 12 years you may be the last Home
Secretary from the conservative party
for a very long time
so one way to avoid that fate would be
to get on top of this crap and get on
top of it fast get people like sir David
Thompson out of the force fire assistant
commissioner Louisa Rolf tell them that
it's not their job to please what
journalists say tell them that it's not
their job to tell people what pronouns
they should or should not use fire
people who can't catch criminals basic
crime can't police it can't do any of
that job get rid of them
there's a job brilliant thank you very
much Douglas